Let's dive right into a pretty
provocative idea.
What if trying to shut down ugly
speech doesn't actually stop
violence?
What if it causes it?
We're going to unpack a theory
that makes exactly that case,
and it all starts with a
fictional but maybe chillingly
familiar political crisis.
Just think about those words for
a second.
The source uses them to describe
the funeral of a major political
figure, Charlie Kirk.
And right there, that single
phrase just perfectly sets the
stage.
You can feel a nation grappling
with an event that's about to
push it right over the edge.
It captures the deep reverence
on one side, and you can just
feel the simmering fury on the
other.
The scene the Source paints is
an America so deeply polarized
that a political assassination
doesn't bring people together.
No, it becomes a Sarajevo
moment.
You know, that one single shot
that acts as the spark for a
massive, massive conflict.
It's the thing that ignites all
these tensions that were
bubbling just under the surface,
not just at home, but all around
the world.
And look at how fast it all
happens.
I mean, the timeline here is
just staggering.
We are talking about one week,
just seven days to go from a
single assassination to a full
blown worldwide political
frenzy.
You've got global leaders
getting involved.
Social media platforms are
completely fracturing, and the
calls for revenge are just
deafening.
So how does the author argue we
even get to a point like this?
Well, this brings us to the
first big concept from the
source material, the latter of
escalation.
The core idea here is that when
you punish and suppress speech,
you don't actually make it go
away.
In fact, the argument is you do
the exact opposite.
The theory lays out this really
clear four step process.
Step one, simple enough.
Someone says something ugly,
could be an insult, a
controversial tweet, you name
it.
But then comes Step 2,
punishment.
That speech gets shut down,
maybe through public shaming,
maybe someone loses their job.
Now, according to this model,
those silenced ideas, they don't
just poof, vanish.
They move to Step 3, festering
in darker channels, you know,
online and off.
And all of that leads to the
final explosive step.
Some of the people who feel
silenced, they stop talking, and
they turn to violence instead.
And right here, just when you
think you've got it figured out,
the argument takes this wild
turn.
The author says, hey, this isn't
just some abstract social
theory.
This is nuclear physics.
I mean, wow, that's a huge
claim.
And it's clearly meant to
completely reframe how we think
about this entire problem.
So this brings us to the
absolute core of the whole
theory, the implosion trigger.
It's this incredibly powerful
metaphor, and it's designed to
explain the, well, the physics
of how words can literally
ignite violence in a society
that's already polarized.
So this is the key question,
right?
The theory isn't just saying
suppressed speech leads to
violence, it's trying to explain
the mechanics of how how can
something as small as a tweet or
a bad joke become the actual
detonator for something so
incredibly destructive?
This slide just leaves the
analogy out perfectly.
On the left you've got the
physics of a nuclear bomb.
On the right are social
dynamics.
So think of a polarized society
as that unstable plutonium core.
They call it the pit.
And the waves of public shaming
and outrage, Well, those are the
conventional explosives wrapped
all around it, designed
specifically to squeeze inward.
In both cases, the result of
that intense compression is a
devastating runaway chain
reaction.
So here we have the formal
definition.
The implosion trigger isn't the
speech itself, and it's not the
violence itself.
It's the dynamic.
It's the process by which one
thing ignites the other.
It's kind of like how TNT, a
relatively small force, can be
the thing that sets off a
massive nuclear chain reaction.
All right, so let's break this
metaphor down at piece by piece
so it really makes sense.
First, you've got the pit in the
bomb.
That's the plutonium core in
this social analogy.
It's a society that is already
fragile, it's brittle, it's
deeply divided.
It's already primed and
basically just waiting for a
catalyst.
Next up, the explosive lenses.
Now, in a real bomb, these
aren't just random explosives.
They are precisely shaped
charges, all designed to focus
the blast perfectly inward.
The author identifies these as
our media outlets and social
media influencers, the ones who
amplify and focus outrage,
directing all that energy right
onto the pit with perfect,
crushing symmetry.
Then comes the force itself.
Compression.
In this model, that force is the
immense social pressure of
public shaming, of
deplatforming, and what people
often call cancel culture.
It's that relentless inward
squeezing force that gets
applied to anyone who expresses
what are seen as forbidden
opinions.
And what happens when that
compression becomes too much?
The system reaches what the
author calls criticality.
That's the point of no return.
The pressure becomes completely
unbearable, and society
basically implodes in a chain
reaction of violence.
Just like that, plutonium core
achieves fission.
OK, so if that's the author's
diagnosis of the problem, which
is pretty bleak, what's the
proposed antidote?
The final part of this document
shifts gears.
It goes from describing the path
to implosion to outlining a path
to prevention.
The framework is called
Protecting the Civic Square.
Now, to introduce the solution,
the author turns to a really
surprising source theology.
This quote is used to set up a
concept that tries to find a
middle ground between two
extremes.
Our culture seems to love total
indulgence on one side and
merciless punishment on the
other.
And that middle path is called
Stern Mercy.
It's a paradoxical idea, right?
It means you protect a person's
right to speak.
You're essentially forgiving the
speaker well, at the same time
you are firmly, loudly rebuking
the content of their speech.
It's an attempt to hold 2
competing ideas in balance,
which is not easy.
So how do we actually put Stern
Mercy into practice?
The theory proposes these 4
pillars.
First is legal restraint.
That means upholding a really
high bar for what actually
counts as incitement to
violence, like the US Supreme
Court's Brandenburg Standard,
which protects all speech unless
it's aimed at causing imminent
lawless action.
Second, institutional
resilience.
This is about companies and
universities resisting that
constant pressure to punish
every single transgression
instantly.
Third, cultural toughness.
A society that can actually
learn to hear ugly words without
demanding immediate punishment
for the person who said them.
And finally, merciful exactness.
This one ties it all together.
It means fiercely defending a
person's right to speak while
just as fiercely rebuking the
content of what they're saying.
So as we get to the conclusion,
the document frame is this
entire issue not as some
inevitable decay we're doomed
to, but as a conscious choice.
A society, the author argues,
has real agency in how it
decides to deal with speech and
dissent.
And this quote just brings the
entire nuclear metaphor full
circle.
Words.
They're like the charges around
that plutonium pit.
The choice isn't whether or not
the words exist, They're going
to.
The choice is how we arrange
them.
Do we arrange them in a way that
focuses all their energy inward
to cause a massive implosion?
Or do we create an environment
where they can just disperse
harmlessly into the air?
And so this explainer leaves us
with this final and I think
really critical question.
In an environment that seems to
thrive on outrage and
amplification, what are the real
pillars?
The legal ones, the
institutional ones, the cultural
ones that can actually protect
the civic square from imploding?
It's definitely a question worth
thinking about.